foreign
let's go out to Houston Texas and talk
to Tony all right hey Tony
how's it going what's up man
thanks for checking my call you got it
all right so let me fill everybody in
here
um
Jenna
when was the when was this original call
uh
uh my wife called in a couple
months ago okay wife calls in a couple
months ago and I made some sort of
statement like I wish your husband would
call me something like that right and
then here you are
yes sir awesome so
number one
you're a courageous guy and I'm it's
it's an honor to get to talk to you okay
most people shirk away and you said no
I'll talk to that dude so good for you
man the second thing is was if I
remember correctly this call was about
hidden money and emotional like all kind
of stuff and I made some pretty bold
statements that I didn't believe the
story she was telling me or the story
that you had told her that she was not
telling me
and so you had the courage to call so
good for you man so let's uh let's just
jump in so tell me you heard the call
and all that right
I did I've listened to it uh
a bunch of times okay so tell me what's
going on in y'all's world
um
I mean am I to to recap or just just
keep moving go move forward go for it
man recap it and then let's uh we can we
can figure out what happens next
well
um
you know it started by
uh you know me trying to start a company
and
um the company not really generating as
much money as I needed it to and at the
time we had separate bank accounts we we
basically had
a financial roommate situation where we
pooled all our money for our bills and
then all the rest of the money was just
hours
so
like what you made what you made was
yours what she made was hers
but all of our bills our mortgage our
insurance all that stuff we just threw
it all into the middle and whatever was
left was ours which you know after going
through the Ramsey plan it was just a
terrible thing that we did for a very
long time sure gotcha
and so you had did you have a separate
business account for this business you
were trying to start or would you just
Reese running out of the family checking
account
uh
not in credit cards and just trying to
get it up off the ground what kind of
business was it
it's just remodeling I build houses and
I you know I can flip houses for people
and
you know there's a lot of money that
churns in it but if you if you take an
extra month on the project you may not
make any money that's right so did you
find yourself having to get money for
the next job to float this job and kind
of get in that loop-de-loop
yeah Ponzi scheme kind of thing and and
I didn't let it affect the household
because I I was so adamant that this
thing was going to take off
so I took care of everything on the
business side but you know I didn't rack
up sixty thousand dollars to that at one
time it was a it was debt by a thousand
purchases it wasn't these big purchases
and you were you were right when you
said that they were purses and trips and
hotels the only difference was
um those were all purchases for my wife
they were to keep up the appearance that
everything was going good because in my
mind I knew like right around the corner
I was going to hit this you know this
big job and it was just gonna wipe all
this away and
things are going to be great and that
that big job never came
so whenever somebody tells me hey I
discovered this huge amount of debt that
my partner has my wife has it or my
husband has it
and
I asked what they spend it on
and they can't tell me oh it was on a
tractor or it was on like all sudden my
house with my garage is just covered in
DeWalt tools
um
no I I bought that dude so almost always
not 100 but almost always somebody's
having Affair has someone has something
on the side
and this money is just racking up and
she never told me anything about
suddenly she was getting all these gifts
and and things she did she just leave
that part out
it wasn't that she was getting the gifts
it's that
I never made her we went from our
lifestyle never changed
so when my income dropped significantly
our lifestyle didn't change and I was
making up for that with
with credit and when Christmas would
come around
I would
blow it out of the water
like I had before and
take until
June to pay all the Christmas off and
then minimum payment all the other stuff
and then
you know after the Christmas was paid
off then
if we wanted Sushi or go to did dinner
or to do this or that I you know and I
didn't have enough like
liquid funds I I just have a hard time
saying no to her so I just would always
take care of it
and so it wasn't a matter of you
spending sixty thousand is that what the
number one sixty eighty something like
that
yeah I mean it it went it was a roller
coaster it was up and down and up and
down because I would
you know
you get a job and you spend a whole
bunch of money on that job and you get
another job and spend a whole bunch of
money on that job right well and then I
went back I went back to work for a home
builder so I had regular paychecks again
and
and then I would do a big job but if I
did a big job and she knew how much I
made that money didn't go towards the
debt that she didn't know about it went
into our emergency fund so if oh here's
ten thousand dollars oh great we can put
that in our emergency fund so dude you
sound exactly
like somebody juggling women on the side
you know that right
I I do but there was no woman on the
side until until six seven months ago
and it wasn't a woman on the side it was
like we you know I was in therapy before
I was in therapy trying to get my life
to also go to marriage counseling
but do you but do you do you understand
do you understand
that you're you're you're running this
this hustle on the side you have
literally a second life a life that is
failing financially of life that is
covered up in shame and you're just
scared to death
and then you bring that energy into your
household
and your wife you have little ones
I do okay everybody feels that there's a
machine running inside that dude's chest
and they start figuring it out it must
be me it must be something else it must
be that I'm not doing this enough I'm
not doing and it gets if people just
start it starts with an inch they just
move a little bit away in a little bit
more away and then you feel that and you
try to spin that machine even faster
they feel that they move further and
further and further away so this thing
starts pretty innocuously
right it start it starts
like ah I didn't make it anything on
that job I lost two thousand dollars on
that job
and then your heartbeat kicks up two
beats a minute
it's a little more stress then a little
more I gotta get another job gotta get
another one gotta get another one you
get one sweet and then you end up losing
five grand on that one
and it just builds and builds
and the whole time when you're saying I
didn't want you to go to marriage
counseling
you see how this was this was after
after the diagnosis after she found out
about the woman at work
um I I went back I went back to therapy
and then I wanted to go with her and
she was she was apprehensive and
you know
I when we had already gotten through the
financial stuff when when the
the co-worker stuff started we had
she found out we we found the Ramsey
plan we combined all of our accounts we
cleared out all of that debt including
all of our cars and everything we worked
debt free except for the house that we
have and the lot that we own
and and we have a substantial investment
and a substantial you know because she
has a
chronic disease we have substantial uh
emergency funds hey Tony Tony yeah
hopefully by now you know this isn't
about money
I'm I'm well aware okay
yeah because I I
when she got diagnosed I panicked
because she you know there were
complications and she was pregnant with
my daughter and
um immediately I I went into I have to
do all the things that I can do to give
her as much time with the kids as
possible and do the things that I'm
doing so I remodeled the house
we could have a a nicer house and
you know I I tried to give her every
second with it with the kids
and I drove a huge wedge in between us
right
where she's she's doing bath time I'm
ambitious I find out you know two years
later oh I wish we would have just could
have switched off because
what you're giving me is is hard but I
thought what I was giving her was was
what could potentially be taken away
that's right
and that that wedge is what
our our friendship
not not our not our Merit but but the
two of us being friends yeah
and then that's where I
I it wasn't even
I wasn't even really aware of it that I
was seeking a friendship outside of my
marriage
and
so bring me bring me to bring me to
right now
so I mean right now I've
I've I've printed out every I've gone to
the credit card companies and had them
send all the bank statements all the
credit cards hold on hold on let's get
before that let's get before that
okay
what you have is a long pattern
of trying to love your wife
trying to take care of your wife and
your kids
in the way that you think they need to
be taken care of
have you sat down with your wife and
said how can I love you today
that we've just recently done that okay
because what you have is you've got four
years or whatever the number is of
trying to create a business that would
make a jillion dollars and I would even
go as far to say is you want to be a
successful entrepreneur
but just talking to you I think you want
to be a guy that gives your wife
whatever she wants in the world
yeah and that you want to give your kids
whatever they want in the world
so much so that you will ignore math
you'll ignore reality because I'm gonna
make this thing happen for them
right
and then you want to be such a great dad
I'm going to make this house amazing for
my wife and kids I've heard her I've
seen what she's watching
out of the corner of her eye on HGTV I'm
gonna give her that
I see how much she's how hard she's
working with these kids I'm gonna make
sure there's not a dish in the sink I'm
gonna make sure there's not a scrap of
trash I'm gonna take it out every day
I'm gonna make sure the lawn is perfect
I'm gonna do all this stuff for her
because I love her so much
and she's sitting in there saying God I
wish you would just come help with a
bath
yeah right and so
um
there's there is there does come a
moment when
people need friends
and co-workers especially co-workers
you're attracted to that's that's a
whole thing it happens all the time I'm
not going to beat you up for that okay
you know right
yeah it just never happened to me I ever
expect to be in that situation nobody
expects that okay and here we are
what I'm afraid is gonna happen is
you're gonna quit
because you've been working so hard for
years
and all it's got you is a wife who
doesn't like you
and kids who are like
because Dad's always stressed and Dad's
always exhausted and Mom's always mad at
dad and dad always whatever
see that's the thing in the last
two months
we've
we've gone to counseling we've had
before we even went to counseling we had
that discussion about
why what I was doing was dividing us and
we went to work on that and I just
stepped back and just treated her normal
because she said well you're doing all
this stuff and you're treating me like
I'm disabled
so I stepped back and I just we we just
take care of everything together and
things have gotten a lot better but
there's you know there's just
I just want to I want to give I want to
be able to like you said I want to be
able to make the ground underneath her
solid and I want to make her feel safe
that's what I want perfect
let her tell you that because it's
really easy to listen to that last call
and be like I'm gonna prove to you
and maybe she didn't ask for you to
prove to her
or maybe instead of running out and
printing off every receipt and spending
hours and she's saying what are you
doing and you're like I'm just trying to
get the instead of that
just to say hey
I did something for years
that was dishonest it wasn't true
and it doesn't matter why I was doing it
because I was trying to give you the
world it doesn't matter what matters is
I did it and I'm so sorry
and then asking her
what is the next step that I can do for
you to help rebuild trust I'm gonna let
you speak into that and for some folks
it's I need to see your phone every day
okay
for some folks it's I need to see all
the credit card okay
for some folks it's every morning before
you go to work I want to look you in the
eyes and we're going to talk about what
we each need that day
everybody's different
but the key here is where everybody's
the same in this deal is you have to
stop trying to solve all her problems or
completely disengaging you got to stay
in gear but you gotta ask her what do
you need what are you today and she's
probably even gonna know sometimes I
don't know
okay cool I'm gonna check in four times
and what you're doing right now man is
all you're doing is taking that energy
and that love and that commitment that
you have for her and you're channeling
it like a laser
right into her heart and she's gonna
tell you how to get there
because Instagram can't tell you the way
your dad did it can't tell you she is
that's your wife
you see that you see the difference
yes
and bro I almost lost it all doing the
exact same thing
okay and I want to tell you on the other
side of this
everything in my marriage in my life is
different because I start the day with
how can I love you today
Everything Changes
because now I've got some direction for
this chaotic energy in this insane
amount of love and respect that I have
for my wife now I've got a place to to
channel it because before it was all
over the place
so did she does she still want to be
married to you
yeah
right now I guess okay
you're gonna have to dust your your
pants off and stand back up
because you're talking like a guy that
got knocked out
well she's always been my everything and
I I have not had support because I can't
turn to her for that support right now I
don't I don't have a
Network to lean on it well two things
number one that's your job to go get
that
okay
number two
um this this doesn't work if it's
one-sided all the way
you go groveling around on your hands
and knees saying I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry and she's like hmm that doesn't
work
the conversation is how can I love you
better today what do you need for me
today and then she has to ask that
question back to you
how can I love you today
and sometimes your answer might be
um man I would love just to spend a
little time with with you and not the
kids
sometimes it might be I'm actually
really good right now can we just watch
a show tonight after the kids are in bed
sometimes it's I miss you we haven't had
sex in like two weeks You Wanna Party
like it can be whatever
but you've got to be honest and stated
out loud and just say it
and I think I've said this on the show
before I can't tell you how embarrassed
I was and now I'm embarrassed that I was
embarrassed because it's stupid
but it was after 15 or 16 years of being
married and things got really rough
that I finally said out loud I worked so
hard for you I wish you would just say
the words I'm proud of you
I think we're in I'm in a similar
situation okay you've got to say that
out loud
and you also have to be willing to admit
I did some things that I'm not proud of
in an effort to keep up appearances
I will never lie to you again
I'll never hide from you again you see
how that's radically different that's a
new identity I'm gonna tell you things
even when I don't know how
then I'm gonna ask for Grace on the back
end of those conversations but I'm not
ever gonna hide a thing from you again
and that means you have to deal with
shame that means you have to deal with
when things go wrong or you get fired or
you get in trouble or you don't get the
promotion you thought you were gonna get
you gotta go home and say it
and then she's gonna feel safe not that
oh no we lost a job she's gonna feel
safe that that guy tells the truth I can
anchor into that guy and we are gonna
figure out what happens next together
that's marriage
that's not one dude trying to be a hero
trying to save everything
now I'll say this I think your marriage
um
is going to be extraordinary
because I think you're all in
and I think you've got the passion and
the love and the connectivity with this
woman
and if you've told me the truth and I'm
I'm not see I I can't see you so I'm
just gonna uh I'm gonna take out your
word
if you're a guy who's been telling the
truth
take it one step further and say I know
what I did was wrong and I'm sorry
I will never lie to you again
how can I love you today and it sounds
so Elementary
you should I should be able to know how
to love my wife you don't
most of us don't
I should be able to to meet my husband's
needs you don't know you can't if he
doesn't tell you what they are
if y'all will practice those steps
little bitty steps and there's going to
be some days that this comes crashing
back on her and she gets sad and upset
and frustrated that's okay that happens
that's life there's gonna be some days
that you wake up and you're bathing in
shame because I should be so much
further ahead in my career financially
that's fine that'll happen so I need a
couple buddies that you can call go hang
out with
commit
how can I love you today
and
here's how you can love me today
it's an incredible dance
it's a credible dance